i want to kick off a new segment with
you okay i'm going to give you some
examples of things that
might not be so great about let's say
the quarantine and i'm going to
challenge you
to see the glass half full instead of
half empty
lamorne are you ready to see things on
the sunny side
[Music]
[Applause]
do i look ready you
sure do okay let's play all right
now most of us are having to spend our
days
in work meetings on zoom but on the
sunny side
on the sunny side at least we now know
that our boss has a dirty
bedroom you can use that for
blackmail material if you want to you
know
that's not only optimistic it's funny i
love it okay
all right social media is addicting and
you can be stuck
scrolling for what feels like forever
and a day but on the sunny side
but on the sunny side i now know that my
ex-girlfriend is happily married with
someone better than me
um this is a real thing by the way
i actually have a whole theory about
seeing your ex
and their new life on instagram what are
the in-between moments lamorin what's
really happening in that relationship an
image is just a moment
i one hundred percent i like to think
that they don't talk at all
and that they have long car rides of
silence
purely for instagram okay
it's saint patrick's day so the chances
of waking up with a hangover are very
high but
on the sunny side but on the sunny side
uh i guess i can do it all over again
with no consequence because hey it's a
pandemic
you know what i'm saying whine anybody
you know and every day is friday and
every day is friday so
it doesn't really matter i love alcohol
that's what i'm trying to say
okay dating already has its challenges
and a pandemic makes it even more
difficult
but on the sunny side but on the sunny
side
at least you can watch all the rom-coms
you want
alone by yourself in your bedroom can we
please open up bars again
[Laughter]
i feel like st patrick's day might be a
giant kickoff
okay we've been officially quarantining
for a year now
one year but on the sunny side
but on the sunny side you have zero
excuse of why you have
not downloaded my podcast yet unwanted
it's out everywhere it's the greatest of
all time
i love it and definitely
definitely watch woke on hulu while
you're at it because it's extraordinary
[Music]
you